yes
yes happy Monday everybody ah you look
fantastic
lying so let's talk about Derek chovin
you remember the Minneapolis cop
convicted for killing George Floyd
chovin was just stabbed in federal
prison likely by some inmate wanting to
gain street cred with his cell block or
MSNBC
now I'm not easy to shock you're talking
to a guy after all who once saw a Cavuto
without
makeup but what an eerie coincidence
that chovin gets stabbed just as a new
documentary examines his arrest and
prosecution comes out and the
documentary makes some amazing claims
and if they're accurate could expose a
pretty big lie a lie that costs lives
including black ones and billions of
dollars and damages and it's at the
heart of the breakdown and Law and Order
and the reason why drugstore deodorant
is locked up but criminals are as free
as a bag of coke In The West
Wing so let's do a quick recap of the
facts in case you were in a coma or
you're Joe
Scarboro in 2020 George Floyd tried to
pass counterfeit bills at a grocery
store while full of enough drugs to make
Charlie Sheen drool thanks to his
erratic Behavior and the fake money the
shopkeeper called the cops that's it
those are about all the facts the public
got after that our view of the case was
based only on the famous video where
chovin was has his knee on the back of
Floyd's head what we were told was that
what chovin did in arresting Floyd was
counter to all police procedure that
Floyd was nonviolent and hadn't resisted
and if you even thought otherwise well
you're racist but according to this
documentary all that seems questionable
now for instance according to the film
chovin wasn't even the arresting officer
the officer who did make the arrest was
black according to the film important
body cam footage of Floyd violently
resisting arrest was kept from the
public for months and judge Peter Cahill
kept much of the key body cam footage
from ever being introduced at trial also
according to the documentary the footage
shows Floyd with at least one pill in
his mouth which he has shown swallowing
to avoid being caught with it now this
is what body cams are for evidence when
facts are in dispute what possible
reason could there have been not to show
that at trial no clue but this film
raises that question it also reports
that this type of encounter had happened
previously with Floyd and he was rushed
to the hospital for treatment from the
swallowed pills but also that in Chin's
case the police called paramedics 30
seconds after Floyd was put on the
ground and that the Medics went to the
wrong location and that caused the delay
the documentary also claims that what
chovin did the placing of his knee was
what he had been trained to do saying
the maneuver is right in the Minneapolis
Police Department's training manual in
fact the body cam footage even shows
that Chin's knee was not on Floyd's neck
but on his shoulder then there's the
autopsy according to the Minneapolis
coroner Floyd had a dosage of fentanyl
in him that the doctor described as at a
fatal level he also had meth in him he
also had a 75% blockage in one of his
arteries hypertensive heart disease and
also covid and so the coroner claimed
Floyd died of pre-existing conditions
and there was quote no physical evidence
that suggesting that Mr Floyd died of
affixation now documentaries are
notoriously biased one can convince you
that there's global warming and then
another can reveal it as a fraud it's
because documentaries often don't
present both sides but maybe this one
presents a side that when ignored still
you got to be careful especially when it
says something that you want to hear and
marshalling all this stuff together it
raises some serious questions especially
since early on I suspected that the
courtroom wasn't impervious to what was
going on outside did you hear what to
Mike Tobin said when he was interviewing
some people when they said hey we're not
going to loot tonight we're going to
celebrate so we were dealing with what
we thought was a sense of of uh
extortion that if this didn't go a
certain way I'm speaking the truth if it
didn't go a certain way there was going
to be a destru there was going to be
destruction we know that why pretend
otherwise come on that guy is so
gorgeous
not him me my point is there was no way
chovin wasn't going to be found guilty
not with the mob just waiting for a
reason to Riot so was it justice served
or was it extortion I say watch the
flick decide for yourself the media
hates that after all so while the
leaders of BLM hang in a luxury compound
that would make the Hamas leaders
jealous all four cops from the ployd in
Floyd incident remain in prison expect
no explanations from Minnesota Governor
Tim Walls or minneap mayor Jacob fry who
were cheerleading Chin's prosecution so
loudly they should have had pom poms to
go with their
skirts ESP expect no comment from
Minnesota AG Keith Ellison who charged
chovin with murder expect no explanation
from the judge who according to the New
York Post later told an audience of his
fellow judges that quote every case you
deal with should be about racial Justice
you know instead of that boring plain
old regular Justice that courts are
supposed to provide for everyone
regardless of race finances or if your
dad is
president expect no examination of the
matter from the Legacy Media of course
who found in chovin and Floyd their
entire wish list of progressive
narratives and expect nothing from our
president who said during the trial that
he was praying for a conviction and who
calls America's law enforcement
absolutely systemically racist look do I
know that everything in this documentary
is accurate hell no all documentaries
come with a point of view but the people
who cheered loudest for the choven
prosecu prosecution are the same ones
who've been lying to us about everything
else so it makes me wonder why did we
believe them then and why should we
believe them
now woke up tonight's guest he knows how
to work a crowd when he's ushering at a
movie theater writer and comedian Joe
DeVito this reporter pressed while
athletes got undressed farmer anavel
sideline reporter Michelle
tooya she's like a can of Mace she can
make you cry and fits in a purse New
York Times bestselling auor fers
contributor cat
tip and they call him the hamper cuz
when men see him they throw in the towel
New York Times best selling author
comedian forwa
Tyrus Tyrus I go to you for for no
particular
reason you know I thought we were going
to talk about all the extra turkey
things you could do soup sandwiches
whatnot but I guess we'll just Dive
Right into this well you know the thing
is every now and then we got to tackle
the the hot button issues yeah you know
and this is a hot button issue yeah and
um I have not watched the documentary
yet which I think is important but uh we
have to make a choice in this country to
where we start
we have to support our court systems
because let's take ourselves out of this
one when I was growing up in La we had
the Rodney King incident where we had
the video where the police were beating
Rodney King it went to court and they
were found not guilty riots broke out
all hell broke loose
right then there was appeals it was this
that whatever and eventually Rodney King
got a civil suit whatever things were
made right in this
situation arguing back and forth about
what happened and what didn't happen
doesn't help anyone if this documentary
has authentic evidence that proves
otherwise then you go through the court
of appeals like we have in this country
either our system works or it doesn't
work because when it doesn't go our way
it never works then we have a
documentary showing and in this
documentary is is it bias of course it
is bias but because who was done by it's
done by uh she's a reporter in
Minneapolis who was taken off the air
because her husband was a police officer
so she does feel a certain kind of way
about this but we have to not get caught
up in the hysteria if you have not seen
the documentary instead of getting
involved in the argument like I said
earlier I haven't seen it yet I have to
watch it my opinion has not changed from
what it was back then but I'm not if
there's something different there then
so be it but it has to be done through
the courts we hate it when the wokes
come after us and ruin our lives we
haven't broken the law but they say we
did something on social media or Twitter
with no courts no a jury of our peers so
if anyone has the issues we should have
we need to look at when you go to court
take it seriously but we need to stop
falling into this traps because this is
a trap M the black lives matters need
this to become a thing because they got
egg on their face right now because they
made a horrible miscalculation with
white America when they wanted to go
anti-jew and finally white people said
enough of this you're not going to blame
us for everything anymore and so now
they're scrambling this comes up here's
their opportunity to change it to go
back to white people hate blacks again
and even when they're guilty they're
free so we have to be careful to stay
away from all that and like if you see
it watch it and form your opinion and
take it from there yeah I feel the same
way you can clap
absolutely they always clap for my
upcoming question you know I have the
same attitude when I went and saw I
could I had no opinions on Barbie until
I watched
it Joe what do you say as a short white
man with a beard yes I I have not seen
the documentary yet
because when do I carve out the time for
a bummer of an experience like it's
getting to the point where the only
thing uncomfortable watching on Netflix
is the fireplace it's just a
fireplace and I I haven't finished it so
don't don't tell me how it
ends but here here's the problem I have
with this is that I'm afraid that even
if it it's
completely changes the narrative on this
will it change what people have to say
for themselves because and and I went
and checked because the narrative is so
important that if you go back to KLA
Harris's Twitter account you'll see she
still has her Jesse smette support tweet
up like we know that that's absolute
nonsense now so the problem is there's
no penalty for being wrong there's no
penalty for saying things that aren't
true because there is what we used to
call the truth which was external from
us and now there's our truth and my
truth and his truth and her truth and
and what people are calling Our Truth it
may be that this guy did not cause
George Floyd's death George Floyd had a
tragic life and a tragic death but it
doesn't help anybody to put people in
jail who didn't cause that and we we
can't let our court system have
predetermined outcomes like that because
it's certainly not going to benefit
black people what do you think Michelle
you are from Minnesota I am making you a
Minnesotan I'm a Minnesota motan there
Greg you got to say it right now you uh
so the woman who made this documentary
is's an acquaintance of mine Liz Colin
and yes she was forced out of her job
and she was married to the guy who was
the head of the police Union at the time
so you can say she's got
she's got a stake in this right however
when you I have watched this thing twice
I was very very interested because it
was in my backyard and our city got
absolutely destroyed as many cities
around this country did over this so I
watched it twice um what is interesting
about it Greg is that when you it opens
up all with body cam video you probably
never saw before and what you see in
that body cam video is a very different
story unfolding than just that viral
video that we all saw of shovin with his
knee down okay so there is a lot leading
up to that there are so the other thing
and she texted me today because I told
her we were going to talk about this and
she said you know this did not have to
happen if the truth was told and she
wanted to give the officers not just
those in prison but other uh Minneapolis
Police Department officers a chance to
share what they went through being
surrendered to the Mob because not only
were these guys thrown in jail remember
that Minneapolis the third precinct was
given up they they left a police
precinct and it was set on fire and it
was ransacked they the mayor and the
governor asked them to just leave
evacuate go let him set it on fire and
that's what happened so there was a lot
that the police department as a whole
went through that really I think this
this film sets out to to sort of just
Expose and let these police officers
tell their stories in a way that they
haven't been able to tell all right well
you know
[Applause]
cat you love documentaries your favorite
documentary was Star Wars am I
right yeah that's the thing about
documentaries there are documentaries
about everything all of them claim to be
explosive uh this documentary I have not
seen it I don't think it's explosive I
think that I mean for example it hinges
a lot on the whole fatal
level of feny in his blood which that
would be fatal maybe if I did it but all
experts agree that that's a level you
could handle if you a regular opiate
user and by all accounts this was not
George Floyd's first time using opiates
on that day um and people have um
experts have said that actually there
have been people who were arrested for
intoxicated driving that had even higher
levels and also after someone dies the
level can be inaccurately high and um
also if you just watch the video he even
though he's subdued he doesn't appear to
be be overdosing on drugs in the video
especially cuz he's saying he can't
breathe and opiates they make you not
able to tell that you can't breathe
that's one of the ways in which they're
so deadly so like everyone's already
said yes she was married to the head of
the police Union in Minneapolis I
understand why she would want to
undertake something like this I I am I
don't see I my opinion has not changed
at
all but it's a good here's the point you
sometimes searching for the truth is
going to be ugly and it and we have to
remember that but the problem right now
in this country is truth is the new
four-letter word and the one side wants
to have nothing to do with it and uh
like I said I'm with cat my opinion
hasn't changed on it again I haven't
seen the documentary but as a as a
people we have to get back to being
responsible when we see things because
if there is something in there that
changes my mind I'm okay with coming on
TV and say I got it wrong because I want
to be right I want to my you know what
I'm saying I'm not an epist I'm just a
dude who lived his life and I talk about
it but I want to be right and so and
that's the problem this country no one
can ever say my bad like we got it wrong
because if we did get it wrong there's
four people in prison right now and I
don't care what color their skin is I
don't want any black innocent people in
jail and I don't want white people or
whomever that's wrong and so this is why
we have our courts and we need we see
all the documentaries about all the
people who are wrongly wrongfully
convicted and get their freedom so if
there's any chance that we got it wrong
let's come together and get it right hey
it's it's a free documentary Greg say
this it's a free download there's no
money being made here from this
documentary and so I would encourage
people to just watch it even if you only
watch the first 20 minutes to see what
led up to the whole rest of the thing
because it's stuff you've never seen
before and I think it puts it an
interesting perspec it frames it a
little bit differently than you might
have she does not claim that he was not
murdered she does not make that claim
you know what was amazing to me was the
mediaite headline that said uh uh chovin
with st on Black
Friday was he at Walmart yeah yeah isn't
that amazing hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else